top iranian general revenge for
suleimani death to happen within the u.s
no one will forget
what we do and that's iran saying it no
one will forget what we do
this is a daily wire story iran iranian
revolutionary guard court the irgc
brigadier general esmali
commander of iran elite
codes uh forced threatened last week
that the revenge iran will seek for
death of jose ma
soleimani the former commander of the
irgc code will happen within the united
states he said we will prepare grounds
for the hard revenge against the u.s
from within their homes as we do need do
not need to be present
as supervisors everywhere wherever is
necessary we take revenge against
americans by the help of people on their
side what a thing to say right there by
the help of people on their side
and within their homes without our
presence i'm going to read that one more
time because it's too powerful of a
statement that he made we will prepare
ground for the hard revenge against the
u.s from within their homes as we do not
need to be president supervisors
everywhere wherever is necessary we take
revenge against americans by the help of
the people on their side and within
their homes without our presence talking
talking about former president donald
trump and former secretary
state mike pompeo who advocated for the
strike behind the scenes ronnie said all
of the criminals who are on the scene
from the u.s criminal from the criminal
u.s president to all those behind the
crime of assassination of soleimani are
under our magnifying glass do you think
this is just talk or do you think
they're actually going to do something i
think the iranians are
an uh
an incredibly intelligent people they
definitely play the long game and they
mean what they say um the the
the assassination of soleimani um i have
a lot of mixed feelings about that
because like that was a bad dude he was
on a lot of target decks um but
cooler heads always said let's not let's
not do this it's important to understand
who suleimani is right americans don't
don't get it um suleimani was
essentially the equivalent of the
director of the cia and
the secretary of defense
and the national security advisor all
wrapped into one person yeah he was he
could have potentially ended up being
the leader of iran that was one of the
guys
he was the shot caller right i mean
he he had he had more power than the
president of iran right he reported he
was a jail
combined yeah think about it that way
those two personalities combined so
is he a bad guy who is causing us a lot
of problems absolutely and he is
personally responsible for the death of
many many u.s soldiers but it is very
hard to uh
to overstate the in fact you can't
overstate the importance of that one
event and the ripple effects and the
repercussions now
this is where our short-term system
actually causes us problems because if
you were going to have if you were
always going to have a president that
was willing to commit an assassination
at that level in office
freaking brilliant move
um the problem is
that every four years
potentially have a guy who wants to talk
to killers
um right and there's only one language a
guy like suleimani understands and
there's only one language that the
ayatollahs respect
um and and you can look at this on the
on the geopolitical scale like what
happens right when when certain people
are in office what does putin do
when other people are in office what
does putin do
right i mean these these are these are
smart leaders and you got to keep in
mind in that part of the world you lose
an election you don't go on your
speaking tour
you run for run for senate right you get
a bullet in the back of the head so this
is survival for these people
um so so your best and brightest and
often cases really do rise to the top
and more importantly if you rose to the
top like suleimani did that means not
only do you know where the bodies are
buried you've still got the shovel yeah
so
you
[Music]
those are those are very very bright
people um and we need to we need to keep
that in mind and it's very important for
the american populace and listeners to
understand that like these are not these
are not dirt farmers in afghanistan
these are very very very smart people
who
um who think generationally and know how
to hold a grudge but but to do that but
to but to really get back at holding the
garage so we talked about this a year
and a half ago i don't know if you
remember this we talked about a year ago
when pr when trump was president we
talked about this conversation when it
happened we talked about this exactly
yeah
and uh i
pretty much we said the same thing about
where iran's at they're not they're not
going to forget i remember you you were
very adamant about it they're not gonna
forget they are not gonna forget and
they're gonna time it
uh if they're gonna do something today's
it would be the season to do it because
the current administration is not gonna
necessarily wanna do anything in
retaliate however
knowing if they really do want to get
back at pompeo
and trump
you know say 2024 comes around and trump
and pompeo get back in
and then their president would they do
it now would they do it then because
revenge you got to do when the other
person is alive you can't do it when the
other guy's gone or would they sit there
and say you know what we're going to
wait because we know if we do something
while trump is around he's going to
retaliate yeah
because you know the retaliation was
they they bombed somewhere that was a
distance they said yeah we retaliated
but they didn't do nothing it was just
to kind of uh out
they shot they shot down a ukrainian
airliner days later let's not forget
that
ukraine has been a pivot point in the
war between um
the soviets and and iran and the us and
israel for the last 30 years so you know
they're like oh well we accidentally
shot down the
the
ukrainian airliner i'm like oh you you
accidentally shot it down with an
anti-aircraft missile but you you were
cleaning it and you didn't know it was
loaded and it went off are you alec
baldwin yeah
i got
three things on that path three things
we were filming something else
one uh
one is man what a sad state of affairs
that we're actually have to sit here and
be like oh as americans like oh what
what if ron got mad at us
what what if that's like that's what a
what a sad state of affairs do something
[ __ ] the united states of america i beg
you i dare you please
please do it
watch what happens let's do it in three
years that's that's that should be our
mentality as a nation that should be our
mentality be like i
wish a mother sucker would
but instead it's like oh god like what
if they do this
what we've fallen so far so fast
as a nation as a people we've fallen so
far so fast that you're right that
that's the general thought right now
that's a bad thing two you talk about
the human traffickers they have this you
know they treat it as a business they
have this loose coalition
how tight are the the autocracks of of
the middle east and the east are putin
ji the ayatollah are are they in
communication one another are they
coordinating against the west do you
think or no
that's a me yeah 100 percent in fact i
think the uh the g putin relationship is
is probably the most underreported
uh geopolitical problem that we have
right now uh i mean it's it you know
it's it
you think it's coincidence that
china is rattling a saber to taiwan and
uh you know russia's on the border of of
ukraine simultaneously yeah yeah i mean
that's that's not and then by the way
putin's playing hardball right now i
mean you've seen him on media recently
what he's been saying
what's his incentive so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]